l'entraîneur de montigny le bretonneux
peut se prendre la tête à deux mains ces
jeunes ne sont pas passés loin de
l'exploit contre tous à carantec timide
en début de match les inhibant ten se
font bousculer à domicile et perdent
logiquement 17 à 14
à la mi-temps on a eu du mal déjà dans
un premier temps à s'adapter à une set
zéro c'est à dire que ils ont fait
sortir systématiquement leur gardienne
de but pour pouvoir attaquer avec une
joueuse supplémentaire donc
lamont a pris beaucoup de buts dans
cette situation là laisse monti le
bretonneux rectifie le tir en début de
seconde période et arrive à repasser
devant 21 à 20 à moins de 20 minutes de
la fin du match mais ce sont finalement
les joueuses de tous le carantec qui
s'imposent 30 à 26 lors de cette 14ème
journée de nationale 2 tous quand même
quand on a bien joué mais
malheureusement il ya toujours un
gagnant un tableau mon analyse c'est
vrai que on a énormément été en échec
face à la gardienne de but on a trouvé
des solutions de tir mais on était aussi
en échec je pense que c'est surtout par
rapport à ça que l'on perd le match
après cette défaite montigny le
bretonneux points en milieu de tableau à
la 7e place du classement
la montée étant compromise le staff
travaillerait déjà sur la saison
prochaine